if i just scoop this bit of
rice out of the pan and stick it under
my tongue
and uh put it in the microwave oh i
don't know her name
i know it is though the one that makes
cooking super sexy
[Music]
i'm sure the lads will enjoy this one
yeah baby
um yeah baby yeah i don't like this
are you joking i i don't i don't want to
know who this
is do i make you horny baby
do i make you horny baby yeah
oh my gosh do you know i have no idea
who he is
ah johnny bravo
it's austin powers oh mate yeah do you
not know i haven't watched
austin powers okay um
oh my god
it doesn't sound anything alive yeah i'm
just so lucky i said duck
how would you do it i'll go oh okay yeah
yeah
even the cameraman's yeah he's impressed
don't do that to me i think i know who
this is and if i just
scoop this bit of rice out of the pan
and stick it under my tongue and uh
put it in the microwave oh i don't know
her name
i know it is though the one that makes
cooking super sexual yeah
and she fully does it on purpose yeah
absolutely
i don't know her name though hey yo oh
what is this man
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
okay easy
oh lois
peter griffin yeah
yo it's your boy
yo it's your boy
[Laughter]
youtube are boxer and uh i i like to
make music now
okay well and
uh today i think
it's a good day uh my party
just got voted in joe biden
oh so close i'm the same color as
ksi oh obama
[Laughter]
sometimes you got improvised i don't
know how to do this
in a voice way but i can do it in a
movement way
what
oh that was a bit mr bean but it's not
this to me
okay what's up britney spears
i don't know i know the scene but i
haven't watched the movie
don't look at me stop judging me stop
napoleon dynamite there it is there it
is
oh
[Music]
and that was first impressions
i started falling into this
pattern of just doing trends seeing what
was you know hot and just jumping on it
yeah i just wasn't happy